hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
kevin samuels can modern oh modern woman
can survive just fine without men
this is the problem with relationships
today
now in one of my last videos i mentioned
that
on an individual level some women can
survive without a man
i wouldn't recommend it i wouldn't want
to do it but it's possible
that was all i was saying but i got a
lot of fans
requesting or like subscribers i should
say requesting
me to react to some like more of his
videos saying basically that that's not
possible
so if you want to know what i think
buckle up
don't forget to like comment and
subscribe i'm getting close to 15 000
subscribers i'd like to hit it by the
end of the week
so if you guys want to do me a solid
modern women can survive without men
yes or no okay my answer is succinct it
is no
but i will say that modern men can't
survive without women
um i i heard you hold on oh don't know
don't before you say that
i gotta true
i mean obviously to reproduce alone
men and women need each other what state
do you live in california
and how old are you 39.
why can't we survive in the world we
built
um so i have a pretty simple argument
and it's that
you all need us to procreate no no no
see that
see listen listen that's
young lady the first woman i talked to
survival and reproduction are two
different things
okay we don't need you to survive we
need you to reproduce
you need us to survive and reproduce
okay this is what i mean when i say
in 2021 women do not need men on an
individual level some women
if i'm calling into the show
i'm not i'm not in control of society i
can't do anything
about society i can only live my
own life so if
i'm a young woman and i invest properly
i make
wise financial decisions i work hard at
my job
financially i do not need to marry
a man to survive
now i want to you know like i hope to
but do i have to or need to
no and i know you guys are going to say
but you'll work for a man whatever
right now i work on youtube so i
actually don't
work for a man so um
that's what i mean when i say on an
individual level i'm not advocating for
it i don't think women are happy that do
it
but that's what i mean i don't know so
much that i agree that
okay well let's go through this then
california what what are you in northern
california southern california
saturn what do you do for a living i'm a
contracts manager
okay um have you ever worked with any
heavy machinery
i haven't um
what percentage of you know about you
the infrastructure is run by men or
women
of the country both yeah
what percent i'm gonna have fun with
this
it's the majority of men but don't women
make like 80
of purchasing decisions what time could
be
oh yeah no no i know you're 39 and
you're writing it you're right there
and part of the issue generation x is
because so many of you ladies don't
realize
who we are the infrastructure
the roads the sewage
trash the power plants refineries
everything that makes things go the
power
what percentage of what percentage of
the power plants the power grids
are run by females of the workforce
i bet it's ninety percent woman i mean i
know actually
give me a number give me a number
probably probably an inconsequential
number it's probably very small
well any inconsequential number give me
a number out of 100
i don't know maybe five percent okay
five percent i'll give you 20.
i'll give you 20. there are three
let's just call it 400 million people in
this country just for simple math
51 percent of female that means there
are over 200 million
women 200 million women
and that means 100 of the men and women
running the power grid
provide for 400 million men and 400
million men and women
you cannot get 20 of people who run the
power grids and everything else
to provide for your gender of 20 million
you would run out of power everything
would shut down
you would die
you can't plant food three
three minutes without water three
minutes without air
three days without water without water
three weeks without food
okay but again in the scenario i was
talking about like
men aren't just gonna disappear right
like it's 20 21 society isn't crumbling
it could but like
what are the odds of that happening i
know there's going to be people in the
comments
the doomsdayers that's when you die
men are already running the existing
infrastructure
if all women just turned into dust
tomorrow
we'd be sad but we would survive just
fine
because we will continue to run the
infrastructure
that's true there's a lot of jobs that i
would not want to do
and i don't know any of my female
friends would want to do
like being a garbage man
anything with tools okay so my risk
my response to that is that your
argument presupposes that women don't
have the intelligence to figure it out
i suppose that's what you're you're
saying you're saying okay okay so so
what in your argument presupposes
that if you snapped all the men away
that you women
could actually go download the
information from
an internet that's still working it's
still pretty supposed that the computers
are working
it presupposes that you could actually
get the even if you had the manuals
what you're trying to say is women i
could not
personally it could go read the manuals
learn the information apply the
information
and run the existing infrastructure as
effectively as the men
are in in
under three weeks look
i don't know why this matters men aren't
gonna disappear tomorrow
insane oh i mean if you're gonna
align a temporal constraint on it sure i
mean three that's not a constraint ma'am
if men weren't here you'd start dying
and the fact that you as an intelligent
woman really believe that
that men who are running the
infrastructure and been doing it for 10
20 30 40 years have been working at the
same power plant
you saying that a woman could just go
get a manual or read it
from day one and she could run it to the
same level of efficiency and
effectiveness
as somebody with 30 years experience is
laughable
no i didn't say that i never said that
well would you say it presupposes
that women don't possess the
intelligence i didn't say you don't have
the intelligence
you don't have the time
attrition would happen you would start
die ma'am
three minutes without air three days
without
water three weeks without food by the
time
women got up to speed on what men have
been doing
for a lifetime what percentage of the
population would of women would you say
would be dead
i would say that none of us would be
dead because your argument also
just like who cares this isn't gonna
happen
i mean it could but like what are the
odds presupposes that
men disappear and boom we disappear too
no it doesn't let me let me explain let
me explain
to you again let me explain to you again
real slow maybe i missed something
did you watch the avengers end game
did you watch the movie avengers in-game
or infinity war
no oh god damn
you ever see the book of the movie the
book of eli with denzel washington
christ um i haven't seen any of these
either
well i'll just give it this way there's
a character in in marvel's avengers
and he had a special glove and when he's
got the special glove he snapped his
finger and he snapped and
when half of the population in the
universe just disappeared into dust
instantly get that concept
half of the people disappeared into dust
i get the fictitious concept
okay good so i'm i'm thanos and i snap
my fingers
and the men all disappear into dust all
that's left is women
all no men anywhere
all the cars that were driving
everything stops they don't even kill
anything
they all safely land to where everybody
on board lives
i'm not even going into consideration
the crashes all women survive all men
are gone
from that moment on you ladies worldwide
are running out of time because the men
kept the power plants running those
power plants do not are not
self-sustaining they must be maintained
and who is going to go maintain them
you have to get women to go someplace
and
learn what needs to be done
get proficient at what needs to be done
in order to keep
all these women she said no women would
die and i'm like jesus christ
i don't disagree like i just
why are we arguing over a topic that's
not gonna happen
you think women are perfect
not at all not at all i just will tell
me how women so tell me how all women
survive
if only five percent in your mind run
the power plants and i give you 20
you can't have 20 percent of people
doing what 80
of people were doing
yeah i just don't think that we would
evaporate i mean you're fictional i
didn't say evaporate i said you
ma'am now you're being facetious
i'm not yes you are i didn't say you
would evaporate
i said you will start dying
do you have you ever been in a blackout
before
yeah what's the longer okay okay
have you ever been without water i mean
what's the longest you've ever been
without power
well maybe a few hours yes thank you
and you lost your [ __ ] how long have you
ever been without water
la used to have rolling brownouts
and this is what i'm saying guys that
women still make these arguments
you've never had to live without but
look at what happened
when a pandemic hit and all the toilet
paper and all the water was all that
stuff was gone
what happened it actually wasn't that
hard for me to find like
there's like a couple stores that were
out but like i just went too different
the logistics chain broke down people
bought all the stuff there was no more
stuff
you are so comfortable living in the
world that you cannot imagine
what it would be like if you were just
dropped in the middle of the world and
said
live you honestly think that if all the
men were gone
the women would go back into their
houses homes condos everything else
and just turn the lights on and keep
acting like nothing happened you go to
the
gas station and it'll be full of gas
people have to drive that stuff truck it
in truck it out people have to produce
it
yeah this is why we need men because i
sure as hell
would not be able to learn any of those
jobs men are producing these things
you and this is what it's showing that
women have no idea how this country runs
you just think it comes out of us out of
a can out of a store
and i'm trying to explain it to you
ma'am in the example i said with men are
gone
are you still going to stick to the fact
that if men are gone that women
in in a short time frame in under a
month can get up to speed and do
everything that men are doing
to save the population no i'm not
arguing that it could we could get up to
speed in a month it would probably take
a little bit longer than that how long
i don't know i can't really say you know
maybe six months
who knows six months six months six
months
and i think it was far longer than that
six months see six months
presumes that things aren't breaking
six months presumes that you just have
to learn how to put tab a in the slot b
and get it running what happens when it
breaks
down ma'am you
don't possess the physical strength to
lift some of the things
and maneuver some of the tools that are
required to fix the machinery
you don't possess it tensile strength of
a man's hand is like 75-10
and t and yours is like 48 ours is like
70 times
stronger than you you cannot lift it
when it breaks it's broke the strongest
women
still are weaker than are not stronger
than some of the most
i'm so bored he's right i get it if men
disappeared it'd be
a bad which means
i you know in terms of this argument
about strength i'm not
i will just see that strength is not
equal
between men and women but i don't think
that women are so
ignorant that they can't figure out some
alternate source for
whatever resource it is that has broken
until they've decided really
really really so the power okay so so so
what you so what she just posited now
lady be real
come on what she posited in our class is
men have built the infrastructure the
way it is right now
and it's working but what she's actually
suggesting is that the men were not
there
that women could come up with an
innovative way to
to not necessarily need to do it the way
men have done it for hundreds of years
women will come up with an innovative
way that will work for a female solution
that produce at the same level
outrageous
we can agree to disagree no there's no
agree there's no
and i'm not saying like
some women don't have what it's take
what it takes to do those jobs but like
you're telling me 50 of the population
disappears we just figure it out
and industries where like
some industries are only like five
percent women
agree to disagree no no there's no
agreement no no no
we don't agree to disagree because
number one women aren't
in the technical fields like that anyway
and the fact of the matter is
this bothers me because so many black
women really think like this
black women want anything else because
you've been told that you're equal to a
man in a lot of ways you're better
and you're sitting here really seriously
man
this is about engine science engineering
technology and math this is
lady that's literally what you just said
it's about machinery this is about
power no power
in a city in l.a if the power goes out
everything is out
nothing works people start
dying there's no running water
where do you go get your water man where
are you going to go get your water how
about that let's just start with you
power goes out where do you go get your
water she said if i now
i'm not i'm not sure where water
originates in this city where i live
okay well but but but but you got three
days where you gonna go
costco probably the beach or somewhere
where there's a water source
now listen listen listen the beach the
beach
we're going to go to the beach where
there is ocean water
where some other waters no no no no no
ma'am no that's the beach
is that what you're gonna tell me you're
gonna ask this lady on the spot what
she's gonna do in this situation
i don't know water potable
i could take it home and boil it oh what
i could take it home in one of the
what on what ma'am you could take it
home and do what
and boil it on what on my stove you said
power not
gas no no but that see gas is power man
i said the power see
the electric runs the gas and the gas on
the electric when they go out
the gas stops the electricity stops see
what i mean folks
she's saying she could go to the ocean
which is full of sea water
salt water and she thinks she can just
simply take it home
and use what men have already done and
go and just simply stick it on
her stove and boil it but there's no
more stove man because there's no more
gas now what you're gonna do time is
okay
well then i will get some twigs light a
match
and then boil it okay so now where do we
go
okay you're gonna boil it you're boiling
water
you got a big old pot you're boiling
water how are you gonna
cap how are you going to where's the
water going to come from because it's
sea water
how are you going to capture the water
that's
well first of all do you even know how
this process works you boil water
so no i don't i don't perfect so so so
so
you will go get some sea water boil it
drink it and then die
because you don't understand that you
cannot drink ocean water
and you don't realize that the water
you're supposed to be drinking
is in steam form and if you don't have a
way to collect the steam
and condense it back down into drinking
water
you would drink the wrong water just
like eating the wrong berry
and see that tick tock that's dying and
see
most women are like you they run out to
the beach
and everybody's at the beach
thank you for proving that you don't
even know how to get water
and you got three days ma'am it's not an
ins it's not an insult man i don't take
it as an insult i listen
this is a fair conversation and i listen
i would propose to you
if you think that all men are capable of
doing the exact thing
no no the difference between men is we
they have
see the difference between me and you is
they go
to their stove and it would still be on
the difference between men
is we already run the infrastructure
stuff will keep coming
we'd still have water we'd have we'd
have we'd have water in our faucet we'd
have bottled water
we'd have it all because we already do
it see that's the difference we're
already doing it
and you and i just explained to you how
you don't even know how to the basic
stuff human beings have had to do since
we've been on this planet
you don't even know how to do it
and the thing is no no no let's stick
here
no don't over talk me you don't know how
to even
understand that there's not drinkable
water see this is what i meant about
bear grylls the island women just think
[ __ ] happens
men would not have to do it because
we're already doing it man
if women were disappeared you know what
would happen we would have an abundance
because the the women that are gone
men wouldn't have to produce for all the
men and all the women
all the men would just have to produce
for the men we would have overflow
because we wouldn't have to carry you
guys anymore
that's the truth
can you at least acknowledge that that's
simple math if you guys disappeared
like that the men who are already
producing yeah okay
i don't i don't disagree i was kind of
bored like
halfway through that um
honestly like
he's right i don't know how to do any of
that [ __ ] i don't really want to learn
like
if i can't take my car to get fixed it's
just going to break forever
second thing i wanted to say is i still
stand by that if you're an individual
woman
you make good decisions early in your
20s
you will not be obligated to marry
someone like if you make good financial
decisions
you can be okay on your own i wouldn't
recommend it i wouldn't want to do it
but just my two cents let me know if you
agree
in the comments and don't forget to like
comment and subscribe